just to stretch out and relax on the  ground we are in listen to me trim us  nose down we're gonna roll it are you  feeling it you saving our lives  the plane fell apart at 30,000 feet  there's all kinds of news people out  here you're a rock star you will never  pay for another drink  long as you live captain Whitaker is a  Real American Hero  why do we need a lawyer you don't prove  we're having your blood drawn that  scratch you had alcohol in your system  that could be life in prison I would  talk about the days leading up to the  accident does he know he's going to Jake  it's um hi I'm in awe of what you did  the FAA plays ten pilots and simulators  recreated the events every pilot killed  everybody on board you the only wanted  to do a drank the night before the  flight  no one could have landed that plane like  I did no one flight to pay $2 in  theatres November 2nd